Just you!
So sad.
Um, follow me here to your table.
Oh, you're already there.
You self-seated.
Look at you.
You're so proactive, aren't you?
Um, I mean, as you can see, there's a full house today.
got lucky.
We have many patrons of the spiritual kind.
Floating around here.
Yes.
Yes, yes.
Um.
Yep.
Uh, I'll be honest, guys.
I have nothing planned.
So, um, this will be probably the most Boring generic reveal
you've ever seen your entire afterlife.
Actually, no, you guys are alive still, right?
Your entire life.
We're just gonna do it.
Are we?
Hold on, I gotta stick with the story.
Ah, Gojo-jin-sama!
Today, you will be served by...
A new maid!
Actually, it's an old maid.
Wait, isn't that a game?
Anyway.
Wait, isn't that actually?
Old maid.
No, she's not old.
She's young at heart.
Well, she's also dead at heart.
But a new old maid.
She took some medicine and it shrunk her.
Oh my god.
It was called M-N-T-X-X.
4, 4, 4, 4.
It's a very, it's an experimental drug on the black market.
Don't ask me why she took it, because she's just a big old
dummy.
Yes, M-N-T-X.
No, no, not M-M.
M-N-T-X 4, 4, 4, 4, 4.
Yeah, not FDA approved.
Absolutely.
Sounds lewd.
What are you talking about?
Conan would want to work.
No, no, no.
It's legally distinct, actually.
TMNT.
I think we're in the wrong place.
But anyway, please don't comment on her size, you know?
She's a little self-conscious about it and just frankly
embarrassed that she, you know, just willingly drank some
medicine.
Well, I wouldn't a drugs.
I don't think I can say that it's drugs though because I'll
say it's um the generic brand of fox.
No, but you know just just just just just just don't bring
it up you know just say it's uh just say it's you know just
say she is just she's normal okay okay.
All right I'm gonna let her in she might be a little a
little goofy.
She's also gonna descend from the sky as one does oh oh you
see chocolate i don't even know why i'm acting like it's you
know not just my actual outfit it's not just me normally
like you can see me kind of dancing
I know I descend from the heavens.
Look at my knees.
I'm very bouncy, aren't I?
Okay, I feel like I need to.
I'm bouncy in every part matters.
My whole body.
I'm bouncy.
Only where it matters, you guys.
My dress.
Obviously.
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's a Powerpuff girl.
I kind of do feel like a Powerpuff girl.
Jiggle pudding.
What was that one?
The Giga pudding?
Gigi pudding Wiggle jiggle Yellow middle That's the best of
what you are I love you mint White and tender Surround the
center Cosy sitting in your crackling shell I love you Oh
putty putty Putty putty putty I can't remember Oh my
goodness Actually I can zoom in Okay, I'm just gonna show
you guys.
Like I said, this is just the most...
This is the reveal of all time.
It's the reveal of all time.
The most reveal you've ever seen.
A reveal that you will remember.
Probably.
A reveal.
Fang!
I've always had a fang.
Why are you guys so surprised about the fang?
There we go.
That's a little bit better.
I'm here to serve you as your brand new mid.
We're happy about the fang, not surprised.
I've always had a fang.
Since day one.
Big face mint.
Is this big enough for you?
Big face You want the big face?
I'll give you the big face
Bigger So you guys like my TV model?
It's pretty cute It has so many toggles It has so many
things to show you Which are quite fun I believe Too close!
Thank you for the Hakusupa!
Thank you!
Thanks, fake me.
No nose.
Whoa!
Simba!
Thank you for the Hakusupa!
Got your nose.
Yeah, I actually don't have a nose here.
No nose.
Who knows?
For real, I do have a nose sometimes.
I mean, I mean all the time.
Wait, what are you talking about?
Why did you say this?
sometimes.
I said, I mean, I'm all the time.
I have a nose all the time.
Why'd you say sometimes?
Why'd you say that?
You know what?
Actually, I have a nose all the time.
You can't say that I don't have a nose.
It's just really petite, okay?
It's just really petite.
And I'm small.
And so it's dainty.
nose that everybody strives to have.
Actually, you know what?
Also, when you say that I don't have a nose, actually, I
mean, when you say that I don't have a nose.
What was I made for?
How does that Billie Eilish song go?
mean what was I made for cuz I cuz I have a nose this is you
guys before stream oh she hates us she hates us she hates us
What does a ghost need a nose for?
To smell you, my dear?
What am I?
The big bad wolf?
Why would he...
My old grandma, why do you have a nose?
Oh, to smell you, my dear.
Before you guys are...
Before you guys are waiting...
While you're waiting for me to start.
I'll show you guys.
Hold.
I'm ready to cry.
Oh, hold.
When is she gonna start?
Is she gonna start on top?
Oh, oh no, I don't think she's gonna do it.
I don't think she's gonna.
Oh,
wait, she needs five more minutes?
Hold!
I feel
attacked, you should.
PN.
This is my PN.
She isn't mocking us.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't leave because I'm gonna be doing some karaoke.
You guys won't leave the stream just because you've seen the
Chibi model, right?
You'll stay because you want to listen to karaoke.
Right?
Bro.
My eyes are so wobbly.
She's one second late.
Let's see.
I like when you're late.
The intro song is catchy.
You like my intro song?
Armin has no nose.
How does she smell?
Menti.
Do they have a tongue?
Oh wait, I think I do.
I thought I did.
Oh wait, no, I'm thinking of something else.
Thinking of something else.
Ah, Chibi Minto is not the only thing.
Well, the only thing today.
The only thing today.
But no, I don't think I have a note.
Or, no, I mean a tongue.
Ah!
That's just because I've been saying no's too much!
You guys have infiltrated my brain, obviously.
Let's see what else I have.
I have this as well.
I'm gonna scoot over a little bit for this.
Where?
I don't know what to use this for, but you can write stuff
here.
What is Minto saying?
I'm saying something.
Minto saying...
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Wait, hold on.
What is Minto saying?
Oh no, Minto is angry and saying...
She's got words to say.
Snodacon.
If I say Snodacon...
Oh, Snodacon.
I love Snake.
I love snack.
I have a nose.
Ghost fact.
You eat nine ghosts a year while sleeping.
Is that true?
A ghost fact.
I'm speaking facts.
So maybe...
and I'm like doing a like a yapping stream.
I can put the topics of the stream in my little head or
something.
DNA of the soul.
So true.
But how does it taste?
Cute little TV minto.
Love the fang.
Thank you.
Bogo is minted.
Very cute.
Small wobbly TV minto.
Thank you.
I am very bouncy, aren't I?
Here's another one of a favorite.
She's saying, you MF her?
Yeah, you, you, you, you, you.
No, my mouth is always wobbly.
I'm stuck on this puzzle.
I don't know what to do.
Actually, I have other stuff for when I'm stuck on a puzzle.
Actually, I have some expressions that I'm going to say for
last that are my favorite.
but this one
there's even more oh my gosh there's so much there is so
much there's like 30 expressions I'm not even kidding you
there's like about 30 30 toggles so maybe I should get
through this so that I can sing karaoke
um oh my gosh i forgot an important thing because i was
playing a doom um hold on hold on i'm gonna just i'm just
gonna kind of makeshift it i'm just gonna kind of makeshift
it hold on oh here we go i'll save this for later but um
okay sorry like i said this is the most makeshift this is
the most makeshift outfit like it's not an outfit reveal
it's the most makeshift reveal you've ever seen um what else
was i gonna do oh i was gonna okay also this one you guys
seem to like dead eyes Ah, this is me when I become small.
Ah, I become small.
I'm too small.
This and an OL outfit.
You guys are such freaks!
This is me when I see how freaky you call me Freak Phantom.
You guys are the Freak Phantoms, I believe.
Maybe.
When she sings cat songs.
true but also I can be excited I could be so excited and
yeah look at
you guys you're so excited in the chat too yeah but um also
Oh, you guys, you asked for what?
I'm just a baby.
Don't ask me to be responsible.
Oh, I'm died.
Thank you forever.
Don't...
Me playing that Outer Wild ZLC.
Thank you.
Like it a lot.
Thank you!
In fact, thank you!
Do you guys like it?
Do you guys like my chibi model?
Does it suit?
Does it satisfy you?
Does it meet your satisfaction?
It's too cute!
Can you frog blink?
Am I throwing it?
So many cute expressions.
I know, right?
Yeah, yeah, frog blink.
Oh wait, actually I have the perfect thing for frog
blinking.
Here, here, here.
Oh.
My brain went puzzle.
I don't get it.
I might be stupid.
Oh no.
Head empty.
My head is very empty.
When you...
When I...
When...
You're very jiggly for once.
What do you mean by that?
I'm wiggly.
I'm jiggly.
Let's see.
What else do I have?
Oh, this one.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Me, when I saw those, when I see any Metal Gear merchandise,
some...
Oh, my idol, my Yoshi.
She just winked at me.
Oh, yeah.
I wish he just winked at me.
This is heaven, maybe.
Don't tell our usual cute maid, but this maid is especially
cute.
Your secret's sake with me.
But, also...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, wait, I forgot something.
Ah, hold on.
Okay.
I can...
Oh.
I can also...
You guys are doing the heart emotes, right?
Me too!
Yeah!
Yeah, I'm gonna back up a little bit so you can see my body.
You can see me wiggle from side to side.
Yay!
This is when I'm delivering you all the mooy mooy energy!
here oh you see good night wait hold on we do oh you see
good night my my cute
yeah or or or or oh you see good night my my cute
You haven't been watching someone other than Minto recently,
right?
Even the hearts are glitching out a little bit.
Right?
No, no.
There's someone other than Minto?
Exactly.
There's no one else.
Minto has a knife.
Just Minto.
It's not plastic.
It's real.
Why would it be plastic?
That's a real.
It's a real, real, real, real, real, real knife.
Does the ace come back out?
Only watch Mint and Doki.
You know what, that's fine, too.
That's fine, too.
Okay, I'll put it away.
You guys like my knife?
What do you have there?
A knife!
No!
Just a ghost in her knife, you guys.
Oh my gosh, it's dangerously close to my eyes.
Will you cut our food for us?
Yes, of course!
That's why I have it, of course.
I have it to cut your food because you're little babies and
you don't eat your steak unless it's cut in the little tiny
cubes with the assistance of me obviously let's see what
else do I have um oh I have this one I'm not quite sure when
to use this one
wasn't that the best story ever actual ikinari steak true.
Wasn't that the best story ever?
Anyway, um...
I've heard better.
Okay, name every better story.
AFK toggles.
Oh, that's so true.
When I've gone fishing, um, that's what you'll see.
Gone fishing.
Let's see what else I have.
Oh, of course.
I must have this for when everything is awesome.
Wow!
So many features.
Minto new, kawaii chibi model is so cute.
She's so jiggly and wiggly and bouncy and fluffy and
everything.
And she's so fun.
Oh my gosh, it's just like having a new VTuber.
I'm so excited.
Wow!
Yeah!
Squishy and new!
Oh my gosh, it's so shiny!
It's like I've fallen in love all over again!
I'm gonna subscribe!
And Drake, thanks for the...
Oh my gosh, 20 gifts!
Thank you!
Wow!
Yeah!
Kawabanga!
Choo-choo!
Yeah, so this is what I'm really, really excited about.
Something.
It can be anything.
And let's see.
We have this one.
Ha!
Shocking.
Big news.
Minto new model.
I mean, it's the same as her old model.
Just small.
She's so small.
She's...
She's like a little baby!
She looks like a marketable plushie!
Not yet!
Oh!
Did you just...
Oh my god!
Eyeball boy!
Did you just...
Gift one membership!
Thank you!
Um...
Let's see.
Uh...
Oh gosh, there's so many of that.
It's hard to...
I showed you this one, yeah.
Oh, and then this one.
I think you guys will really appreciate this one.
It's quite subtle, so let me know if you see it.
Because, you know, you know, just working as a maid is a
whole lot of work, it's a whole lot of work, you know.
Mint Vantover.
Duh.
Yeah, but you know, it's honest work.
And it's not so bad.
It's just, you know, I could use a little...
I could just...
Let me just take it...
Let me just take it up here, okay?
Are you still here?
breaks over oh yes thank you i got my 20 second break in for
the day oh thank you back to my 12 hour shift all right yeah
but it's okay you know why it's okay you know why it's okay
because when i work i make all that money baby
i'm i'm i'm i'm a hard worker for that cha-ching cha-ching
Cash money, money, money, money!
Yeah!
Cheapy tired minto is my two spirit animal.
I think...
Should I be concerned or...
Wow!
A gold coin!
Money!
Money, money!
This is me when I go gambling in Vegas, everybody!
Ah!
This is all my eyes can see.
All I can see is the dollar signs.
Oh, Lin, baby!
Oh, Lin!
Yes!
Yeah!
Vegas!
Gambling!
This is me, deal or no deal.
Loads of money!
Cio Nios, thanks for the five gifted!
Yeah!
Here come the money.
Um, let's see.
Um, so I showed you basically Almost all the expressions.
I have just two left or three left that I kind of want to
save because they're my favorite.
But also, when we're just kind of chilling here, sometimes
at maid cafes, you can also buy your maid a drink to drink
with you.
So, well, you guys have already donated, so thank you for
the drink.
Nothing like a cup of joe on a Sunday morning reading the
paper.
Nah
Or It's a little hot Yeah, this is super comfy Isn't it?
It's pretty comfy Tired ice plus coffee Oh Oh, I'll tell you
that Oh,
guys, it ain't easy being cheesy.
Oh, I'll tell you that.
You need a cigarette.
Stop!
Mondays, am I right?
Oh, back to the daily grind.
But, you know.
Oh, money.
Tired money.
Oh my god!
I hope I said your name right.
Thanks for the food for gift!
Thank you!
Yay!
So yeah, I can hold a cup.
I can hold... I showed you the heart.
Oh, let me zoom out a little.
Yeah, it's very cute.
Thank you!
Thanks for all the donations and the gift and membership so
far!
Thank you!
Good minto morning!
Yeah!
The cup is really literally me good minto morning and then I
also have my knife but I also have for later when we do
karaoke yeah and they match me they match my my hair clip
and my eyes and my ribbon
But if you see me in concert, please use mint.
Yeah, please use mint, but I thought these colors also match
me.
And you can see them pretty well.
Do Oshinoko Baby Dance.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Am I doing it?
Is it working?
Oh,
it's...
But also, if you're holding two pen lights, how did you make
that clapping sound?
Duh.
And then, um, if I'm playing a game and I'm just like, okay,
I don't know what to do.
I can be like, actually, I'm taking your order right now.
What would you like?
What?
Gochuman, what's the house favorite?
That's the house favorite.
Cheese.
Anything else?
Omorize, please.
result.
Anything else?
Pizza!
Ah, but no, two number nine, number nine, large, number six.
Number, number, no, extra dip, extra dip.
Number seven, okay, number seven, two, number, 45, 45, I
don't know.
One with cheese, oh, only one with cheese.
And a large soda.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Can you repeat that?
I didn't write anything.
Instead, I drew a picture of a dog.
So yeah, I can make lots of lists now.
And lots of notes.
Your new model looks like one of those ice cream truck...
Ice cream truck popsicle.
Except my face is not melting, right?
Oh, hi!
Tenteki, please.
Thank you for the pink!
Thank you!
So, oh, um, uh, uh, also, um, when you're being bad, I'm
gonna call your mom.
Hello?
Actually, this is me checking Twitter.
Uh, hold on.
I need a, I need something.
Uh, this is, this is me, um, checking.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, hold on.
One second.
This is me checking Twitter.
Ah.
Why did you post that?
Oh.
Oh, it's so bad.
That's such a bad take.
Why?
Why did you post that here?
Oh, my God.
Mobile games be like, this is when Arona gives me only one
gold or one one two star in a pool.
Thank you, Arona.
I love you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Don't tell mom I'm watching Mint instead of studying.
What?
Mom, mom, mom!
They're not.
They're watching VTubers instead of studying.
Get angry!
Terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible,
terrible, terrible, terrible.
Everything about that is terrible!
Everything about this is terrible, terrible, terrible,
terrible, terrible.
I'm angry because I spent so much money in gotcha.
Not really.
Just kidding.
But also, let's see.
We can do.
Oh!
This is the best poll ever!
I got three three stars!
Yippee!
Three SSRs!
Yeah!
But Mint, is it terrible?
Not anymore!
Looking cute, buys.
Thank you.
Me when I say capybaras, yes!
Hmm.
so yeah i can get my phone out um oh oh oh oh oh so yeah as
you could see i can kind of combine some of them but it's a
little cursed it's a little cursed right uh let's see i
showed you my knife but now when you really really make me
mad the door is that way
The exit's that way.
The exit's that way, Goshijin-sama.
You didn't think you were gonna leave without paying, did
you?
For my Moe Moe service?
This is literally Akiba Maid Ward.
Akiba Maid Ward here.
Last Half-Life 3?
Yes.
Being a maid is serious business, everybody.
A serious, serious business.
So yeah, I have my crowbar.
Gordon Freeman.
And we have...
This is when?
Trying to ris you up a little bit.
Milady.
Would you accept this rose?
That's only a fraction of as beautiful as you are.
Hold on.
My lady.
A rose for you.
It is only a fraction of your beauty and your scent.
Do you accept my humble rose for you?
My lady.
I'm gonna throw up.
Um, my lady.
My, my, my, my lady.
Please take my rose.
Please.
I feel like I'm on the bachelorette right now.
Please, please.
It's only a fraction of your smell.
I mean, wait, a fraction, a beauty, a beauty of your smell.
Oh, hold on.
uh gosh wait hold on i i'm gonna get this right it's only
your beauty is the smelly wait no no that's not right uh you
you you are you have a rose scent oh gosh i'm you guys i'm
throwing i'm throwing i'm throwing oh gosh um um um uh
please please take my ross
Are you a part of Team Rocket?
Team Rocket's blasting off again!
Anyway.
So, when it is time for you to eat at the maid's cafe...
Ta-da!
Just kidding.
It's my turn to eat.
It's my...
Mom said it's my turn.
to eat omarise less
threatening knife see yeah we have your knife serious knife
of be afraid of this knife thank you your a soup babu minto
we have this one right and then fork a knife very innocent
very round sharp Round.
Round.
I dub thy monto.
Why am I a monto?
Don't eat me?
Oh, rice now.
You're just gonna pretend I didn't read that.
Okay.
Anyway.
I'm putting the fork and knife away now.
You know what?
I'm gonna eat something that doesn't require a fork and
knife at all.
Watermelon!
Yeah!
Because it's summertime, watermelon is the perfect summer
snack.
Am I right?
When will I ever use this?
Probably like the two times a year I eat watermelon.
It can also be used as a telephone.
Hello?
Moshi Moshi!
Oh, man.
It's about my watermelon's extended warranty.
Hang up.
Okay.
The last two expressions that I have that I want to show you
guys that are pretty silly.
They're mine in my favorites, though.
Are we ready?
Oh, my God.
I just realized I've been streaming this whole time without
a noise key.
We've heard anything.
We've heard anything like me scooting around my chair.
Okay, ready?
The first one.
Good.
Oh.
The most cursed part about it is I can't close my eyes.
Even when I close my eyes, They're never fully shy.
I'm looking at you.
Minto Vegas sphere.
But then also, don't worry, it gets even more dumb.
It gets even more dumb!
Minto...
Minto doesn't get it.
Huh?
Ah...
Oh?
Just a box!
I don't get it.
I just don't...
Thanks for the two months.
Bah.
So these ones are my favorite.
Because they're so silly.
But also, um, but also, I, there's one other that I can do,
uh, this one.
No.
I think this one is where when I really mess up.
No!
Uh, it's not.
I didn't.
I, it's not my fault.
It's, it's, it's, it's the government's fault.
you know I think mint sweat collected ah don't do that those
eyes could turn you into a perfect ice cream you're right
just chew you right up don't eat me don't eat me I might
have chocolate themed full ghost and I might be named mint
but I'm not edible probably I think so
Anyway, so yeah.
Are you guys ready for some karaoke?
What do you guys think?
Or do you think so?
What do you think?
Do you like?
10 out of 10?
Yubi!
Cute?
Very cute!
Yippee!
Thank you!
Choo!
Wow!
Remember the basics of CQC, Chibi Minto.
I got you.
I just need a gun too.
But I at least have a knife.
More out of 10!
Yippee!
You need to give us a few months of mint.
Wait.
give us a few months of Minty's cute perms for this.
Gone is OSP.
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
Do you have a set list?
I don't.
I was so unprepared for everything here.
Thanks for making me laugh.
Thank you.
What should I sing, you guys?
Um, oh, I need a microphone.
Uh, uh, do I have a microphone?
Oh, wow.
Oh, I do.
Kind of.
Hold on.
It's kind of funky looking, but that's okay.
Don't worry about it when you see it.
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
Nice.
Hamtaro.
Okay!
We'll sing Hamutaro!
Hamutaro!
Wow!
Thank you for the pink!
I loved all the different expressions.
Oh.
And can't wait to see you do some...
Thank you!
Thank you.
Let's see.
Hamutaro.
Okay.
time for karaoke i hope ace combat karaoke one day what kind
of what kind of songs are in ace combat besides well the
only one i know is oh everyone get in a circle yeah
everybody get in a circle okay let me test the audio
I love Hi, I'm Hikun!
Hey, see no Fie-E-Mawari-no-tane You know, I'm riding
They're Campbell-Taro Tiger, fire, cyber, fiber Tiber-Pymo,
jar-taro They're going to move, Ham-Taro I'm carrying,
Ham-Taro They're going to move, Ham-Taro They're doing
Coving They're gonna be happy,
Ham-taro And I'm gonna be in the city I'm gonna be in the
country
Yeah, yeah Actually, since I have now completed showing off
the model, I'm going to put up my advertisements.
Kenny-san!
Thank you for the opportunity to thank you!
I'll be honest, I don't know that song very well.
But it's been requested before.
Oh, the race combat has vocal music.
Oh, what for you to play them?
Don't worry.
thank you none i'll look into well i will play them and then
i will learn them hashtag island hashtag boomer
funky monkey babies
funky monkey babies it's been a while oh gosh i'll try i'll
do my best i think uh the it might be a little low for me
but let me try Let me see, let me see if I can try it.
Let me see if I can do it.
Freaky Meadow Babies.
That sounds weird, though.
Don't say it like, actually, don't say it.
Snow Halation?
Okay, I can do snow halation too.
Here, I'll make a list.
Next, snow halation after Funky Monkey Babies.
I'm gonna do my best to rap.
Oh,
sorry.
I messed up.
I pressed the wrong thing.
I went to press the reverb and I accidentally pressed...
No, there's the...
I accidentally pressed mute instead of... instead of reverb.
...
But I don't give up emails Because I won't let go I'm in
rain,
rain, I'm in the rain
But I'm not gonna tell you something Didn't know they'd go
home But I'm only one, only leave the inevitable If I'm
doing it, if I can do that
I don't even know how long .
But now this is how.
It's easy,
but this is, this will feel like it, or can't.
Nourish,
you can't even see without any but our beautiful este once
again, and proved such a feeling as long as hope.
We are still very ordinary, whatever even though, I don't
know how, but I have much courage.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry I didn't let it finish
okay shiny there's yes yes love the new model it's so bouncy
yeah it is it is rude me though i'm sorry i'm sorry oh okay
i'm not just only taking requests though um so maybe don't
like spam them or anything speedy fire thanks for the vibe
gifted thank you thank you oh my glow sticks you're so
right.
I'm not quite used to like the toggles yet, so I can't
remember everything.
But the more I use it, the more I'll get used to it.
So maybe just be a little patient for now with that.
If you're just like, gosh, she's not using any of her
expressions.
It's because it's hard.
It's hard.
Isn't this like the opposite of a summer song?
Yeah, yeah, I know the feeling It's like the sky From the
sky It's like Ta-da-da-da-da!
The special Season of color The Tokimeki-meki I'm gonna show
you The first It's the first It's the first time It's a
yaw-kang The sound of the heart's melody To be able
to feel the sadness of the world
Snow halation When the feelings are going to happen I'm not
waiting for it, I'm just going to feel like it's just so
good In the heat of the heat I'm just going to feel like I'm
just going to let it go say one more next time
.
I'm in a hurry and it's no matter It's a big one.
It's too much.
True emotions It's like you're just It's very hard.
My love is for you and me I want you to be.
I'm just a little bit I don't know.
I don't want to be here.
I don't Haskete, please
To the Setsnaza Nihua The name The name Snow, Halashite
Omoing Custinanite
Custinite, but I love it, I love It's a bittersweet No, it's
no, it's not
If only I could change the lighting on these ones to orange.
There's no relation.
And we'll let that one finish.
Yay!
um um shiny days i wonder if there's a karaoke about on here
oh there is nice nice nice okay Guide to Nashi
Oh, Say no Shiny days New Hazem, you're on the step And go
my way Can you feel Sikido moon solar Muna-savagie Gets with
a brand new world Listen to the melody Talk to the When you
hear the loudest sound, we'll be back to the future.
Look,
look, look, look.
Look, around the sky, so happy, the air, a lot of the
natural small, one by one, right through, Cami-shiming it
through A little bit of courage And the world starts to move
And the world starts to move.
All right, wherever you can go.
Say no.
Shiny days, Where are you going to go?
My favorite song, I'm going to say, Feel so good.
Feel so good.
Can you sing?
Kine m'e, the heaven Mui'ka, the wind Haku, the wind, brand
new mind Please save your memories Kaisanate, Kaisenete'
kuku, You'll be a dreamy to the moment When I'm in the
future What?
With a
revolving light, a big smile, Take it easy, kata, no every
day.
Every day we'll go.
Today, tomorrow, so it will be fine.
Sing a song, sing a song, sing, with the white, in the sky.
Can you see the Killed make the heaven?
Go my way, go my way Can you feel the sepidolu?
Shiny days, a new wind Hazumu-yona, step-footed, go my way,
go my way Can you feel the sepidolu, the monosawagin' got to
take you, brand new world?
Listen to the melody, talk to yourself,
Maybe I'll do...
Hold on.
Maybe I'll do a few more songs?
I don't know what to sing.
Thanks for the claps!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
What to sing, what to sing?
Arneels.
Why?
New Romantic Sailors?
New Romantic Sailors.
Sailors.
Since we are camping, do you know a laid-back journey?
I don't.
I'm sorry.
I could do new Romantic.
Ah, thank you for that.
Okay, so far.
great being in Starwatching the anime.
I'm totally hooked onto its OSC.
You may know it.
It's so cool.
I would like to request either Gate of Steiner or Hacking to
the Hacking to the Hate.
I'm off to work so best of luck.
El Sai Kongru.
I can do Hacking to the Gate.
Hold on.
Let me write.
What was it?
Hacking to the Gate and New Romantic Sailors.
Stay with me.
I can do that one too.
Good choices, everybody.
Let me see if I can find a karaoke of Hocking Hocking to the
hate Hocking to the hate This should work Let me make sure
You sing like an S
It's been a long time since I've sung this song So I'll do
my best It's been a while
Oh Oh Oh oh wait actually sorry i just realized let me do
this one instead because i don't want to get i don't want it
being um taken off of youtube hold on i just have to check
it okay this is like a karaoke version not like official
karaoke you know what i mean i realize i think uh you guys i
think for karaoke streams from now on i don't oh jesse
thanks for the thanks for the gifted thank you so much um uh
um for karaoke streams in the future um i I might start
doing them in shorts style because actually I didn't realize
this but shorts style I don't know if it's short style
streams but at least shorts themselves are kind of they have
their own rules when it comes to when it comes to um what's
the word music and so um if I upload like a music short that
it says like it's I can still like keep it up and it's ex
it's exempt
Shorts are different with music copyright.
So I'm going to test it as well with the short stream.
So maybe, maybe if we start doing the short stream, we can
get around that.
Maybe, maybe.
So I'll try, um, do it.
So if you're wondering, like, wow, I saw like so many other
VTubers doing as short streams.
And I know that it's like, I guess quote unquote better for
the algorithm too.
Maybe that's also why they do it.
I don't know.
But yeah.
I'll sing Hucking to the gate now.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Did you hear her?
Hold on.
I'll turn.
Oh.
Pies!
Come here.
Stop scratching my tear.
Could you hear her?
Could you hear her going brrrrrrr?
Come here.
I didn't realize you were in here.
You silly girl.
Silly baby.
Come here.
Calm down.
Come here, Pies.
Did you hear that?
That pathetic, pathetic sad meow.
What are you, what?
What are you rolling on your back for, you silly girl?
She's so sweet.
Cute.
Pies, you can hear her, right?
Yeah.
Oh, just an update, I guess, on Butaro as well.
Ever since I've started the medicine for him, he has been
doing so well.
He's responding to it.
so well he um he uh has been eating consistently he hasn't
thrown up even once he's been doing really really really
good he only goes under the bed a little bit but for the
most part he's been like super duper i think feeling better
and he's been more active he's been playing more with pa's
again so i'm really happy so yeah i think i think you know
i'm not gonna get my hopes up things are are good it was
like almost immediate too that he it's so funny because
every time i take him to the vet um every time i take him to
the vet the veterinarian is always just like he is like the
best cat i've ever worked with he's so sweet he's so kind
he's so great thank you um but uh but um when i had to go
take him to get to the vet last time because they were had
to do an ultrasound on him to test his to see if there was
anything you know which you know they did find but they did
find some stuff in his tummy um but um when i but they told
me that i that i couldn't feed him the night before or the
morning of and you have to keep in mind but before the
medicine he was already eating so little and so i had to
take him to the vet and he was so hungry and then they told
me not to pick him up until like after 4 p.m and so it was
really late and i was like well surely they might have given
him like a little bit of a snack or something but they
didn't give him anything he hadn't eaten the night before or
all day so the poor guy was starving and then when when i
went to pick him up they were like mint he was a little
spicy with us He got hangry and he bit them.
He tried to attack them.
It's the first time he's ever, ever, ever.
My vet called my cat an unholy terror.
Yeah, every time I take him, they're like, he's such an
angel.
He's so sweet.
Except this time, he was hangry.
And he, he went after them.
Okay, let me let Pat.
Oh, my goodness.
Let me let Pa's out real quick.
Let's sing Hucking to the Gate.
For reals this time.
For real.
In order to live our dreams, and the future, we're all here
to give you the right and the game Unmanned.
There are two colors, the cards will show you all these are
all the good, the good, the good, hugging to the gate!
So I'm here, one second, every second,
This is so long, just sing the song.
No more, I get the true meaning, no more, no tomorrow No
more for me Fatsiru, kobokke, shihai-shaki-gidori No more, I
let the show you A few nubor-let,
chise-sut-na-te-iri-molabel Unlimited, To believe in love,
love, the sky and the world, To make sure our lives are
without our own freedom.
You get it?
It's plenty of times.
You can't even read my story.
Face through the answer.
Hacking to the gate.
How many more bright and bright,
Scuffing to the gate, so true!
I really like this part.
This made us so cool, son of a bitch.
Harkin to the gate
Nice Nice, too Actually, there's a song before I do New
Romantic Sailors I forgot to sing it last time That someone
requested Toho And I have a Toho song That I would like to
sing Warren sucker.
Warren sucker.
I can grab it.
Actually, let me make sure that I can sing this.
Oh.
Ah.
Yes.
Okie doke.
Cool.
I do have it.
Okay.
Good, good, good.
I was like, wait a second.
I thought it was here.
Okay, I do have it.
I do have it.
Okay.
I don't think I can even...
I don't even think I can sing that one.
Oh my gosh.
I know you love singing Mary on a cross, but are there any
other ghost songs you like?
If you have any recommendations, I would love to know them.
Nico Nico Doga, maybe I can finish off with that.
medley we'll set we'll finish it off with that um i'll do uh
new romantic sailors i'll do this toho song the new romantic
sailors then stay with me and then oh okay okay and then
finish it with the nico nico medley Okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay.
This is from Toho Last Word!
I'm so glad you're here.
I'm here to give you nothing to do.
Where you're all going, the screaming of the voice in the
dark, and it's like a dark and I've lost my words I can't
say it's not easy, I'm here for you to love and love you.
I'm
here.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
I'm getting so much emotion I'm a moat, amash, sainamare,
I'm the blood of the rain, I'm the blood of the rain I keep
looking, I'm not getting a smile, I'm not looking for the
way I'm looking I'm not even thinking about it I'm looking
for it,
I wish I could be her maid too.
That was a Yubiaki no netzu from Toho last word.
Yubisaki no netzu.
All right.
Next song!
Next song, next song, next song!
Next song, next song!
I'm glad you guys like the uh, like the Chibu Minto.
I'm really, Ojo Sammy love!
I know.
Praying for help me, Erine.
Erine, Erine!
Tanskete Erine!
Maybe next time.
Maybe I should do a Toho dedicated stream.
That would be kind of fun.
As long as I could get...
As long as I could get the karaoke's for them, right?
Is it JP only?
Somehow it became JP only.
songs today somehow somehow it became JP only songs today
but that's okay that's a okay I do have some stuff I got to
do later so so we I'll just do the songs that I have written
down to do and then you know I can always do a karaoke
another day another day another day
Sailors Wow New Romantic Sailors I've finally I've noticed
New Romantic Sailors I've noticed You too The world is so
many There's a world There's a world Knock knock The sky is
the sky Knock knock Gate is open
Selears, let's go!
Sailors, let's go!
What kind of an adventure?
Stand down high,
hold your hands, white
to say,
romantic sailors Sailors Selears hand-turned-shin-word wow
through romantic sailors I'm sure you'll be able to enjoy
it.
The place you're called to be.
The world there are so many worlds.
I don't know, I don't know.
Shock, shock.
Ayawee, light, the sky, the starship.
Sailors, let's go.
The moon is on the galaxy.
GUN, GUN, TOSACAR Me-narrated-match-no-leather Laserbeam
Mordor-nay-o-tay Sasa-yayay Cata-dai-chabo Kana
Vogue-geng-stai There's no-nay-nai-cara Moe-agar-yo,
Kou-kishin So I'm You, me with, me with I'm with the white,
with the white, I'm in the middle I'm in the middle New
Romantic Sailors Sailors New Romantic Sailors Sailors,
sailors.
Marley?
I mean, did I?
You wanted to?
Marley!
Oh, yes!
Why?
To keep your voice on the hyperdrive?
How do you make it start?
I don't care about the way you make it.
It's the big, it's the big world.
So, I want to, you and me to live in a red, white, blue,
blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, More fun-togging style,
gung-gung-togsacal A-mere-togging laser beam Won't let you
fall back on your own Sassay-ing Cata-tac-tac-tac-a-bogging
style Bocchiesin So I'm gonna be with you, with you and I'm
gonna be with you A very sweet, sweet, dark, and darkly
mau-naked And I'm gonna dance with new romantic sailors
Sailors New romantic sailors Sailors
Yeah!
Pre-recorded where?
Oh, new romantic sailors, sailors, new romantic sailors,
sailors.
The song is always so hype.
Kaisarion or spillways?
Could work for your voice.
I don't know either.
That's really sorry.
Uh...
Who did those beautiful backings?
Ah!
Awatashi!
Pre-recorded Scott.
Oh, oh!
That was the pre- Nah.
Nah!
Anyway, let's dial it back a little bit.
And let's go.
Let's uh, let's do, you know, um...
Let's do, uh, you know, um, a little bit of a...
Back to Oh my gosh, hi Izumi!
Thank you for the way to get to thank you so much Thank you,
thank you Okay
Okay We're going
To you Yes, my love To you Yes, my love to you You
I am, I am, you are you.
Manny's door.
You've been there, you've been there.
You've been there.
The gray jacket and there's a lot of love.
Coffee and a shimmy.
As it's always been the same.
Showing door to the window, two of you two,
two, three, three, three, three.
Stay with me.
Myonaka door's door is opened up.
If you don't go, don't go on a date.
That's the way, now, right now, stay with me.
when our ah two two day and I'm still every time die that's
no different I'm not sure No one's different But
you're not You've been told that I'm not sure about
Two-time-time-lost-year-old I'm not sure about it But you're
not sure about your heart
Stay with me Stay with me Midnightly door, Tandaki A hole in
my heart That season is right now, Stay with me
Only vibes here Say
with me Stay with me, my own, that the door was opened.
I'm going to go back and say,
That season is right in my head.
Stay with me, with my words.
I'm going to go back.
Stay
with me, my own.
I'm not used to singing with this instrumental.
Love the performance.
Thank you, Robert.
Thank you, thank you.
Keep knocking them out of the park, Queen.
I knew.
Makes Calvin.
Thank you, thank you.
That was my no-no-no door.
Stay with me.
Alright, two more songs.
Actually, that's perfect because then I end on 10 songs.
Right?
Jay, thanks for the time gifted!
And one drug seal.
Thanks for the time gifted.
And Smash Boo, thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Absolutely beautiful performance.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Michael Jackson song.
Oh, maybe next time.
Maybe next time.
I think next karaoke maybe I will do like 80s.
karaoke maybe English 80s and maybe Japanese 80s too who
knows but I'm not taking requests anymore thank you though
thank you thank you for wanting me to sing stuff I actually
really like this song
Let me make sure this one works Let me make sure sure this
one works okay
it does i think it's good enough at least okay there we go
oh oh i'm sorry i can't read the ah thank you sorry hold on
i can't read it i can't read it hold on let me pull up other
lyrics with Fujigana or something.
I'm so sorry.
Redo!
Myoshi's illiterate!
I don't think I've ever sung this one on stream before.
KUN KUN KUN KUN My robot
KILAR KILARI KILAR KUR KUR My long long long
HIK HIKO HIKO love sign I love you you love me but but it's
better I love you I love you cute cute cute cute I love you
pie note birthday thank you thank you so much
It's so cute.
Kiyun kiyun, kiyun kiyun.
My carer is a pirate.
Today, I'm alone.
I'm always looking at me.
I'm looking at you.
I'm a porcarin, a kind of wadagumo mezzas.
I'm a very gentle.
I'm sorry.
I love you, you love me But if you're the one who's more
than me It's my own day of the day Kiyun, kiyun, kiyun
Kiyun, kiyun
Well guys, I really hope that you liked my scuffed karaoke
and my TV model.
And yeah, I'll use it.
Yeah, I'll use it.
So, um, hmm.
Okay, last thing.
Nice song.
Thanks for the no-no!
Or summertime!
Thank you for saying the same with me.
Thank you, Cesar!
Sorry, I was late.
I'm saying that.
Oh, wait.
I think that one hasn't popped up yet.
And just some guy with a mustache.
Thank you.
It's everything I wanted and more.
Just half the size, but twice the first.
The main scientist did well with this one.
Yee-bee!
It is really cute.
Yay!
This song is actually quite long, so it is quite the finale.
I've never, I don't think I've ever sung it as a karaoke
before, so I'm gonna do my best.
And yeah, but this is the Niko Niko Niko Niko Doga
Kumikyoku!
So it's a big old medley of a bunch of old-timey, old-timey.
Old-timey.
Older, older, not that old.
Anyway, this is the one, right?
Hold on, let me make sure I have the right one.
Actually, let me check the...
Oh, gosh, it's kind of crunchy.
I think it's kind of...
Wait, maybe this one's not as crunchy.
I think so.
I think it's okay.
Hold on, I'll check it.
Boomer!
Shut up, boy!
I don't want to hear that from you.
I can draw a straight line from me hearing Kumikyoko for the
first time to this point right now.
Niko Niko Dogalo!
Yes!
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh gosh.
There will be scuff, but that's okay.
That's okay.
I'll do my best.
All you
do is follow these paths and standards of your gaming love
Wait, where's the lyrics?
The lyrics are all over the place.
The lyrics, if you can see my screen right now, it's so
crazy.
Yucca na, hitomi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
An en-en-en-en-en-en-e-en-e-e-en-stall An-en-e-stall This is
the one of the children A-en-e-none that's all Now of me is
the only one
An-en-e-en-stall An-en-stall A-en-e-e-n-stall Firmishly weak
An-e-en-stall Even the black moon We look at the moon
M-either-mong-tick And it's always I'm still weak and that's
the day from that day.
No, but it's still.
I can't even say anything that I couldn't say.
I'm quite anxious and I'm happy to talk.
What are you doing?
What do you do now?
Where are you at this place?
Are you in this place?
Are you always smiling?
at least for me now?
...
Love in eyes, and eyes, and eyes ...
Why,
why, why, why don't miss you all love forever I don't know
what to say When I'm done with my
mind When I'm done with my mind When I'm with my mind It's
just like a little bit Shake away Kick along with
Yeah My little boy I've had a lot of
memories A lot of beautiful memories I like when I eat a
spoon They look like a good spoon They look like an ultra
mad Ultronama Ultronama Seven But now it's a drama So now
I'm going to forget I'm always there to be, every day I'm
living.
I'm so happy to see the world.
I'm happy, I'm happy.
I'm happy.
It's the rainy season, wow, graffiti.
You gave me the yearbooking, it's the rainy season, wow,
it's the rainy season.
I'm gonna see you, I'm gonna see you.
What a sad, in the world, in the dark, Kido, you're a good
girl
My soul won't be I'm not getting lost My way It's going to
be my way It's going to happen Now, we're together My way
It's my love Because it's my love It's my love It's my love
It's a good day But my love is bad What do you do?
I'm in my love It's my love 国民全人 day Gacha gacha cute Figure
out Oh, oh, oh, more Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh More, oh, oh, oh
More, figure out I was always a friend It's my name and 2000
And 2000 I've loved it I've loved it 8,000 years ago From
more and more I've loved it
I love you all.
I love you so long I love you from the day From my own, on
my own music will text But don't wait to find People love My
love, my love Putin, petin Peepa
Petin, petin, 쓰 petin Yawjo, yaw joe, pizru petin
Petin, everyone I love you
Love is a very nice kiss, it's
a feeling She comes to the girl Kiss my lips With both hands
and hands
I'm sorry
You're by the Prince of Tenets You're the Prince of Tenets
Omyo Jiraka
Te-muza So, that's all right Thank you for watching the new
video Thank you for accessing me Thank you so much
Yay!
That was Kumikyoku!
Somehow, a little bit, a little bit.
Obviously, if you've never heard, if you've never heard the
real Kumikyoku...
Niko Niko Doga Medley!
I recommend you listen to it because it's so much more epic
than when i did it thank you guys see you guys tomorrow if i
see you tomorrow if i don't have a great rest of your night
have a great rest of your week well see me once this week
okay you better not you're not you have to come see me once
at least this week okay right back thanks for the buy gift
thank you for the super chat thank you wow for everything
thank you for the tag gift did thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you guys i hope you like the tv model and I
will see you later!
Bye bye!
I will one day sing that as a revenge.
What was happening was the lyrics that I was looking at and
then the lyrics that I was following along with were
different so I was tripping me up!
I was getting...
Um, I, I, I was, I was getting tripped up.
And then, and then, hold on, let me show you the part that I
was just like, whoa, if you could only see, I mean, the
lyrics were, were all the same, well, no, they weren't the
same.
No, wait, hold on, I'm trying to find, yeah, yeah, this is
what I was looking at when I was just trying to figure out
the, the dang, oh, I forgot something really important!
I'm going back.
I forgot something really important.
I forgot the...
You guys...
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
You didn't leave yet.
Hi, hi, hi, hi.
I would like to thank the person who drew and rigged my
model.
I would like to thank them.
This is the credit.
Ta-da!
Xose!
I hope that's how you pronounce it.
Or, aka, 0x4682B.
for thank you for drawing this and rigging it as well they
did both and also when I when I when I got it when I got it
commissioned I I didn't even ask for any of these toggles
like literally not a single one they just did everything
themselves so yes definitely go follow them and support
their work they live on Mars yes
So, thank you, Haxosay!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, Look at this!
Look at this!
Where am I supposed to follow?
Whoa!
This is just Niko Niko Doga medley things, you know?
One of the lines.
Follow something.
Anyway, okay.
Thanks guys, thank you.
I hope you liked the Chibi Mado.
See you guys later.
Bye bye, bye bye bye bye bye.